before we begin I would like to think
that the monitor the service members
remind us to remain in the arrangements
the microphones
thank you chair it is much in Spain
that's beautiful that the roads that I
knew we have engaged the services of Tim
who's our founder engineer and he has
supplied the minds to work well so that
everyone in the room around here makes
mostly
streaming is also very dependent upon
the owners or microphone
and please will you remember to raise a
hand if you're not in this first flow
and we wish to speak so that Tim and
thought the microphones and they might
can be brought to you to use please
speak directly into the microphones they
are designed and I still have been very
close and do not work because not close
the chair of a person who do not
standing speakers
from the microphone as possible
then we'll switch off the microphone
when you've finished sleeping and please
remember don't listen those papers as
immunities can be hooked up by nearby
microphones thank you thank you
[Music]
which is the election of chair and
Council
everybody knows
phenomenal
thank you councilor Parker
what happened
thank you councilor Perry
we have emotional football scores and
secondly and I please see that is run by
a show came so this is a great place
foreign
thank you
very practical grabbed my almighty God
I've been elected to the office of care
of the Northeast pharmaceutical Council
so I take that property upon myself and
resuming and safely to feel the duties
of it according to the best Frank
Goodman and the benefits
I will uphold the Constitution
take the right to the Council of members
and food to be Associated for civic
Unity
I swear to be carrying out the office of
chairman I will bear through Allegiance
with his mother
because and processors according to law
so help me God
thank you colleagues and that includes
everyone thank you for your support
you and I are grateful for the council
for learning is the opportunity once
again to serve the districts of
Northeast Derbyshire
we have been privileged to witness
firsthand the plethora of people and
organizations across the area
that make a difference for others in so
many ways
we can testify for the selflessness of
our own song Hero
yeah I'm comfortable
I am a strong advocate for civic Rome
being a political in every way
they should reflect every person in the
district regardless of policy
I like to believe that Gene and I
succeeded in doing this previously I
will do so again in the coming months
in any case
Gene and I are from opposite sides of
the political offense
so we have canceled one another out
thank you for Colleen who recognize the
importance of an apolitical Council
chair
many of you were brilliant in your
support before
and I hope we do so again
we have a range of events that are into
entertainment as well as raise funding
for our children's charities
our appeal is to escape Austin
they are grounded in a passion for doing
their best for cancer patients and those
important to them
compassion is their what word
the hospitals provide an essential
service for people in our district
our ass with you is to assist us to help
them
they can assure you though we won't be
doing overboard too much in fundraising
so have limited planned events for
7416 in total
well enough of week one
I'm joking that's about the paper start
we're in
I am living proof of the new
administration's green credentials
I am a recycled Council chair
however Gene and I ultimately working
just as hard in making our Township
crowd along with assistance we represent
thank you
I'm speaking of Truth
previously the council chapter instead
of chapter of the Reverend Smith green
who supported its Council in many ways
including leading on Civic events
National occasions that is Remembrance
from the Platinum Jubilee
and counseling and support a difficult
times
post lockdown
and I know this was appreciated by staff
and members alike
who moved to the appointed Pacific
year who is the Reverend military
by the Reverend dick green where by
almighty God that I will carry out the
office of Civic chaplains at the
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
I was the thought that chairman of the
council the council's elected members
and its officers offering Council Circa
and concerts to them
I also swear by almighty God that in
carrying out the office of Civic
chaplains I'll be faithful and will bear
True Religions to his majesty King
Charles III is as until second according
to law they'll help me God
congratulations Reverend Nick green your
stone happens to be there in readiness
also reinforcing our council's
commitment to the Armed Force of
Covenant
the appointment of our Civics today
all right ambassadors in the district
and supporting the Civic function
this year they are called for Robin
Lomax and Corporal Ewan Ridley of 331
Squadron foreign
foreign
[Music]
if you have been marked by significant
fundraising for supper underlining the
Armed Forces of government
which was epitomized on the community
than we had on Saturday and ultimately
we're here it was an absolutely
fantastic turnout of the community on a
wonderful extremely day until we hear
more about that in a moment
also this is Northwest able supported by
her husband and Jack as a console during
the answer this year and I know that
some people want to make a special
mention of your contribution Council
councilman
thank you thank you very much yeah
congratulations
I can't think of Rebecca versus serving
that role and really look for your Civic
year and support new Advantage if we can
that is going to be your advancing
fundraising episode so very well done
thank you and Diana I could say a huge
thank you for you and yes uh as your
comment on such a brilliant year of
share and those has been already been
said I think many of us would agree that
sharing these meetings is something that
most of us wouldn't rare it but I think
you were posted in a really steady and
calm style that never really got
flustered despite being quite heated at
the base in the game but and I obviously
had quite a big role in pulling together
the agenda presence so I do have to say
some responsibility for the fact that a
couple of them went wrong as well in
excess of three hours and I'm sure
internally at least I was probably
testing your comments but you never want
ready to go and I really want to say
thank you for that and that being
Testament to your very good character I
don't really want to say what an amazing
ethic student raising for fighting
foreign
to the remote
to reply
thank you for the kind words
a chair
man's office
and at the end of my third the
coronation was being transfer through
space
foreign
[Music]
along the way
without any chairs but things are the
characters which isn't always about
raising money although in fact there's
certainly upgrade itself
this year has given me the opportunity
to represent and promote not only our
councils but to raise awareness for
supper
well at the end of my term I have this
mostly spoke to ever since asking in
this chamber with 105 of them being
moving to a few success
on Saturday after this honestly for
Sunday Sunday
proves to be an exceptional events the
sun's promises but unfortunately provide
that couldn't arrive enjoying as soon as
the second position
[Music]
without the support of the very special
things on and I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank all those involved
for the exceptional work carries out on
Saturday when you ever smiling suit
compare station National daily thank you
a great deal and walk the same this
Council should be proud
for the volunteers friends assignments I
can see this thank you Lord
for making a good day into a great day
seriously several other fundraisers
and I'd like to so thank you for
opportunity to thank councilman I thank
you from heaven with you for their
health and support
thank you ladies
I kept the final total race and my
character has not been confirmed as
there are still managed to come to you
from your own substance events
that we're looking at around over six
thousand pounds
happens
on behalf of the council
gives you your practice
and appreciation from accounting
foreign
are there any decorations
find some six seven
what 2023
kind of proposed that they are true and
accurate records
the council Dale the second week Council
blueprint for those in favor
anyone again
and the abstain changes
so it would come to like let's have an
election of advice there of the council
do we have any nominations please
okay
and phenomenal counselor yeah
do we have a second there
Council Smith
are there any other nominations
all those in favor
all those again
and the abstention
you've been duly elected you can receive
your bank of office
election of the leader of the Town store
nominations please
I nominate Nigel Parker we have a second
councilor they see
in your denominations
all those in favor
anyone again
oh yeah
I've been carried congratulations
Council Market
you are willing either
sleeping a quick remove the address of
gratitude
why don't you really like the league of
the council so oh new Council of Boston
thank you
thank you thank you everybody and thank
you chair uh I launched out my pair of
leader of this Council by welcome you
all to congratulations congratulate in
your team
uh for those of you who this is your
first time on this Council I hope you
enjoy your four years
and find it rewarding I believe it's a
great privilege and an honor to save
your community uh and Well Done
everybody I would also like to thank all
the H counselors and served prior to the
election and they will either by choice
for a bottle of the electorate I no
longer members
whatever your political is public share
this is an important part rather than
democracy and we should recognize those
who give up their time to fill that role
we should also say thank you to their
families who may sacrifices that allow
us to say that of our community
I'd also like to thank Council Dale uh
and councilor Guildford
for everybody especially its own
I don't like to make special mention of
my friend in colleagues
he has been the best developed at the
moment but she was an excellent
counselor and the store author of this
Council for many years I'm sure the
whole Council will wish a well we didn't
get chance before since we said well
uh so best of luck to wear and also I've
been made aware last week that yeah Pete
ring it who was a counselor on this
Council died
and not many of you'll know
but he was another story of this Council
they were chair with Blake off parish
and the county councilor so uh
family and friendly
and also account I never got the chance
to thank all the staff involved in
winning the election
uh and so I would like to take this
opportunity to do just that and say
thank you to them I think everybody had
gone be done man you know that that read
down didn't go through uh it was a
challenge the election with all the
problems with politics and the
introduction of vulture ID if it was an
efficiently and impartially by the
Democratic Services here
this election saw the introduction of
alter ID
and I think it'd be remiss of me not to
mention that uh we don't want to put any
barriers in our people who jumpsuitable
even if one person stand away in the
election that's one too many we want
more people especially at local
elections I think the 30 there now uh or
or below is not great for democracy
on a personal note I'd like to thank the
people in North Greenfield who'll return
all three labor councilors with an
increase majority and they've stood by
me personally even when the labor party
was going through difficult times
finally I'd like to also thank the
people of Northeast Derbyshire for
putting their faith in the labor
department this election was the first
step but this District I thought you
need and that's the election of a labor
government and the labor MP to represent
Northeast Derbyshire
a new Administration means new policies
and it changes the way North Beach
established your way we made it clear
well before this election that it was
our intention to change the culture of
this Council
the fact that the media reported there
is a bullying and the counters felt
compelled to resign was not something to
be proud of
with that in mind we are keeping to our
word and offering Civic positions to
other parties developing with a position
of chair of the council and supporting
the appointment of the last year's
Conservative Vice chair into this role
congratulations Council taxi on your
reappointment of that year and I'm sure
that you'll exercise your role in a fair
and non-partisan way
I'm also sure that you will represent
the council to the best of your ability
and probably raise loads of money well
not too much Matthew we've been told
and also a lot to congratulate councilor
Morley on being elected with the vice
chair who will take on the church role
next year late class is a proud interest
of providing chairs for this Council and
I know that you'll do the role just this
installments yeah
I've made this change in the spirit of
cooperation with reality for the
benefits of all the people in North East
Derbyshire hopefully it will also put
down on some of the political posturing
and point scoring we've had in the past
that's not to say we don't expect to be
able to account
that's after all what the job of the
opposition is
but we are confident that we can be both
open and transparent and be able to
defend any challenges that might come
our way
during the election we made several
pleasures for the election and we tend
to deliver on them even in difficult
Financial Times
that we know this downstairs
we should not forget that developed the
vote this year the previous
administration had to put the council
tax and take on 800 000 out of Reserve
that's going to be a challenge having to
find around 2 million in Savings in the
coming years so it's not easy Pat I'm
all involved in difficult decisions
we promised to be a Greener Council and
we start delivering on that Promise by
setting up a dedicated environment
excuse me committee
the focus on climate change and how best
we can play our part
at how the work of our partners and
other agencies impact on our district
and now we can challenge and assist them
to bring about Improvement
as part of that commitment we are
offering the vice chair of that
committee the council adelington
Springer
as he will speak out for that law and
that's challenging question but we're at
some towns you'll see that there's a
threat and run away from me which I can
suffocate to challenge we see part of
the democratic filter
we also intend to return to Dedicated
sustainability officer to help us
deliver our climate change objective
we also promised to be a safer Council
we can't ignore the fact that for a
decade the current conservative
government decimated the police CPS
report on the Probation Services
anti-social Behavior there was one
unacceptable now have to be tolerated by
some communities because agencies
they need to deal with it
the role of this Council may be
secondary distance in this field what is
not unimportant long-level anti-social
behavior is increased and we all know it
can have a terrible impact on
principal's lives and well-being
especially if you are a vulnerable
victim of it my own village at Wingfield
experienced some of the worst
anti-social Behavior this district has
ever witnessing and I'm eternally
grateful to the community safety team
here at nndc well just to deal with it
what they were stretched to their limits
in doing so and so they need more
resources if we can do more to all the
victims of this type of behavior and to
intent to add to the capacity of the
community safety team and support the
work they do
we also want to make sure we can do as
much as we can to support the police
we promise to be a cleaning Council and
we are going to start delivering on this
from it by reviewing the road sweeping
sweeping regime and have a look at the
ground's maintenance schedule to see
what more can be done
we will also look at how we can better
help with those volunteers the world of
their own initiatives and help their
Community decided but we also recognize
that there's a balance between between
keeping a place now and promoting it's a
big Pride but while recognizing the need
for biodiversity and climate change
objectives
Insurance start that balance within the
current Financial restrictions will not
be straightforward and it will take some
time
another key priority of the doubt is to
increase the number of affordable social
houses in the district buying a home of
your own has become a dream for farther
in many
and yet the last Administration wasted
their four years in office and failed to
address it
until they're a changing government they
are limits to what can be done the one
thing we can do is to say that this
account for plans to put Regional Homes
at the heart of what they do and to use
it to deliver on this commitment to
provide more affordable properties for
rent over the next four years we have
already started by undertaking the
governance of Europe we know that we'll
see the appointment of an independent
chair
we're also reviewing the technique to
Marley's Avenue with a view to having no
social outing as part of that program
going forward we'll be looking at an
ambitious affordable housing in the
council plan joining with the policies
of this council is the way to bring
those homes and I hope to be able to
report back to the council later in this
year on both plans
doing an exam
to provide a more professional
environment we can turn your papers over
women uh going from this chamber the
juicy will avoid him up this thing and
at this Council I know to work that way
finally I want to mention the issue that
dominates many households in Northeast
damages far too many people in this week
are struggling with the cost of living
poverty level of Volunteers in and
residents are living with the oil
prospects of having to pay their bills
and feed their family
without the money to do both the Prime
Minister may be able to socialize
Ordinary People but I don't think we are
again there are limits to go up the
district now to license can do but we
are looking at what other measures can
into can we can introduce or Champion to
help people however one thing that we
can do is to make sure that they get
access to Quality welfare advice when
they need it I can therefore announce
that is reminded to reinstate the grant
to the establish your unemployed work is
benefited so that people of Northeast
Derbyshire thank you
can use it to get the help they need to
navigate the welfare system that is
designed to be conflict and detail you
dare all about the most determined this
is just a start there's multiple and
I'll use the subsequently need things to
spell out more of our plants plans we
have had time to see and examine the
challenges that well-being when cheers
and I look forward to working with you
over the next four years thank you
let's do counselor bobcat and just on
behalf of the council would you convey
our very best wishes to Becky Hill thank
you yeah you mentioned that she's there
not well and I'm sure everyone would
want to know that we are thinking of
you also mentioned Peter rickets
and those of you who remember Peter will
know that he was a true Advocate that
played golf
and Northeast Derbyshire and he served
his community well at various tiers of
local government righteous to Derbyshire
County Council he was certainly vocal in
the council chamber and committee
certainly positive in his views without
ever being personal and he always bought
the sense of humor to what he had to say
I think it's only right and proper that
we just have at the moment's reflection
in memory
from a former colleagues
thank you everyone
so I can stand for the leader of the
council to confirm the appointment of
Deputy leader and cabinet portfolio
holders for the 2023 24 Civic deals
Council Market
thank you
I think have you got that in front of me
I think we have that now we've already
got a religion
yeah as you can see
it's been circulated members should have
it in front of them
uh
sorry combination TV leadership really
uh adults or that the factory where they
definitely did
uh obviously in the finance with myself
and the Barnett and the student
leadership you're working as a
portfolio for Council services
uh the open asset the embarring
environment in place to be picking and
health and Legacy around and as you can
see there we have lots of one position
on cabinet but we upgraded more
children's Communications
while saving money
after Fortune movie
thank you councilman so we're moving
having noted the your appointment so
we'll try to 11 review of the old
Snapchat and terms of reference so I'm
going to hand over now to the director
Finance of section 151 officer which is
definitely
thanks chair
s
if you consider today the
recommendations
Independence
clearly the person has a combined early
on speech and function so the first step
conversation are separation of the two
and not an event was really expensive
Council
of reference in the current Constitution
remain largest purpose they do still
reflect the combined world today as they
will benefit from every research that
was trying to reflections
are there any comments or questions
Council Smith
Richard
um I've looked at the report on uh I've
got reservations about the
recommendations from tipster that um
they wanted to co-op
um independence with the
experience as it says to give us a
program technical expertise I'm sure the
office is here I've got that expertise
and we will rely on them and uh could
guidance and
we'll we'll see what comes out of it um
we're only late people at the end of the
day I'm not a qualified accountant and
I'm sure if we do get people on
um they could um drown us with with
their technical knowledge but I think
once more I'll rely on
guidance through the process thanks
it used to respond to that
yeah
that's that's fine that's no problem it
is best practice I think there's
guidance and it certainly feels safe as
required so the idea is a special
experience within these kind of whether
you don't have to co-op they're just
trying to write down it with regards to
experience so absolutely
you have a comments or questions
but we'll move to the recommendations so
we need to want to propose it please
Council Barry
thank you and the second there
thank you Council Burton
for those in favor
anyone again
the abstentions that is Carrier thank
you
so item 12 then initial proposals for
scrutiny so I'm going to handle the 100
page service and managing director let's
increase
to consider
proposing for spiritually committees for
the new firm so we've just heard about
one of the drivers for change to the
current domestics in the report that
James Pierce uh read out and that means
to separate our Authority and scrutiny
functions and the great creating of the
Standalone or gets connected
another driver Mr James bow is the
developing council plan
which is effectively the business one of
the council for the next four years
the role of student mechanisms deliver
yeah of that plan our kids
they will provide the checks and
balances on the effective delivery of
this one and on the date reviews on
targeted work we're unnecessary in
support of the successful delivery of
that plan
it's proposed that alignment with the
American objectives contained within the
plan
takes place so that each security
Implement you have a clear Focus
individually
and collectively all scrutiny
communities will ensure a comprehensive
coverage and connection to all aspects
of the council plan
so in recent times
well recent time crop Jerry Lewis
have dramatically and quickly the world
around us can change
the new council plan is intended to be a
dynamic one or non-static plan one that
conflicts an adapt to meet the
challenges maximize the opportunities of
today
[Music]
there will be an additional connection
thread running through the organization
right from the front line right back
here
Council this will complement the
Performance Management framework
that will help with transparency and
organizational quality of purpose and
add another source of momentum the
operating environment
it's alignment to the plan and the key
objectives will allow the whole
organization to flex and change this one
system
as and when we need to either act or
react and so in everyone is brought
along on that journey and ensuring
everyone is aware of the changing
direction or understanding that the goal
posts are blue and why and more
importantly what we're doing about this
this organizational connectivity and
Agility will help this Council be best
place for us to collectively deliver the
positive outcomes to the communities
that we serve
so 2.3 in the report uh there are
proposed names of the Committees and
listed from 2.4 on which is a bit more
deeper about how
it's great to make committees will
operate
being established and we've known
councilors on submitted
and the second recommendation is that
delegated authorities given to the
assistant director of governance and
Monk and officer to a point
uh the members in four studently
committees in accordance with the
proportional interviews I mean
consultation with the relevant group
leader and to appoint members who are
not in political groups with that chair
I have to take any questions thank you
and any commercial questions first of
all Council ball okay thank you Council
Dale
yeah
very eloquent yeah I don't know I'll
always speak to me
uh no that that somebody talked that and
I think it yeah
the audience is to align it better with
the the count of the American Delta plan
and all that sort of stuff and it will
be a chance for councilors to bring new
ideas uh and get me more involved in the
council business uh and and hopefully
these committees
uh will will function as if you use this
guy so I'll can I move that foreign
that's banging
councildale thank you thank you can I
start your fight congratulations
Jennifer Parker on your elections leader
of the council uh from migrants
perspectively very virtually intensity a
very active opposition uh and holding
the new Administration to account in the
best interest of the Northeast salvation
residents but we will do so in a uh in a
sensible rational and restrictive way
and we will not oppose proposing Stakes
uh but what we think what is where we
can work with you whilst also holding us
um the uh on this paper
broadly happening with it the only thing
I would say that
um
video doesn't feel like there's a huge
amount of change it feels like a bit of
name changing of Timothy James which
which is fine the environment existed in
a different format before is a working
group has obviously but
um
thank you any other comments All
questions
it's been moved do we have a second
degree Council Barry
all those in favor
anyone against
the abstentions
and that's carrying thank you
imagine 13 then proportionality of the
council committees and advisory groups
Bloomberg
um I'd like to deal with this in which
is the first is the number of members on
committees and the proportionatives
committee these are on attach the report
in front of you there's a formula for
working without
um in the legislation and we have stuck
to that formula
as you can see there are three political
groups with purposes into the political
Branch roles
um we allocation of saints and I'll be
happy at the end of this to take any
questions
the second part is 25 degrees
in the neighbors
um
as we have any questions I'm going to
ask for a delegation for myself
to appoint the members of the two
licensing to understand its buildings
and Finance commitment and planning
Community crossword important employment
through the proportionality rules I mean
consultation with the relevant group
leaders and children family members for
emotional political groups
thank you
let me go into all questions
not remove the recommendations you have
a proposal please
foreign
thank you all those in favor
anyone again
and the abstentions
and that is Karen thank you
your little Titan 14 then appointments
for chairs and vice chairs are committed
into the paper has been circulated with
nominations
so are there any comments or questions
about those nominations
after Shipman
thank you chair um for the fifth year
running I will mention the fact that I
think the basket is should not be all of
um
Administration however
what we've done in the some of the um
allows on this occasion of course I
would like to amend it so that the
children
just
like to win everyone
for that Council Hancock he machine just
be
thank you yeah
unfortunately this was emotion it was
considered within the last six months
and therefore it cannot be moved again
without having evidence as a third of
the membership endorsing it they can't
propose it
machine to support it
Israel
any support for that
I think that that's it then that's
that's the drawing and counselorship and
thank you
so where you have the scheduled
appointment with the chairs and wives
there do we have a nominated The
Proposal please
yes
Council burton all those in favor
all those again
and the abstentions
thank you
all right from 15 proposed Central
meetings for 2023 24 Municipal year
that's uh
thank you chair
um review the number of changes
experiences it was proposed with members
of people need to recharger
[Music]
the rest of the children will then be
presented as an accountant for criminals
I mean we have some schedule up to July
the 31st of Victorian newspapers
any comments All questions about that
it's not going to remove the
recommendations
supposedly I don't know if you're a
second
um thank you thank you councilor Kerry
for those in favor
anyone again
any abstention
thank you Kerry
Richard 16 appointments outside bodies
these nominations to represent the
Council on external organizations and
again schedule has been circulated
any comments or questions before we move
to moving the recommendations
I apologize for that
so we're our China person
uh no just uh just delete the two words
I think Brian Wright and uh
um manage can understand I think just on
that it was a long list and uh we were
pointed to the main sort of uh outside
bodies but we will review all the
community ones I think the intention is
to write out they're into and see
whether they're still functioning and
whether they still need people on them
basically and there's a delegated
that we can add people to that list as
and when yes term and I've always got a
delegation within the delegation team in
the Constitutional Amendment
thank you so uh Council Dale
thank you I noticed there was a Gap
online
if that was a gap of
intentionally
would be very happy to
the Nigel counseling Market mentioned
unemployed workers benefit is that going
on the list
no I don't think it's good
yourself
not nominated outside thank you again
thank you so um councilman Dale request
that you Constitution
for Council Gillette
thank you
any other Financial questions or you're
going in force going on
Council Renee
yeah on the other one I was on March
they know people's workers
anymore now that's what we said there's
lots of
I think don't exist but we'll come back
if there are some of the functioning and
they'll need we will be you know go and
share that round as well
counselor
well first I think it's just changed its
name
I think we all we can all put the handle
what we talk about on this two of these
that we don't seem to exist anymore and
as Council Market said I think we need
to be an overhaul and look at these so I
think the agreement is that they're
taking away weather appointments from
the uh controlling group that was that's
their decision but they'll carry out the
review of those that no longer are
functioning Etc that's right and we'll
come back this Gap
let me ask what some of the what's not
there
um
right thank you councilman so um
with the removal of the two names that
we started off with
um
recommendations so to you Council balls
are you proposing your remains that are
currently standing yes yes no I'll move
that thank you do we have a second
all those in favor
anyone again
any abstentions
that's Carrie thank you
item 17 review of the Council of
constitution so we'll reach 100 of the
United governance and monitoring officer
which is
part of their work thank you the
standards committee to remove the
Constitution amongst recommendations to
the council for changes in Constitution
at this time officers also take the
opportunity to make changes and
non-substanding changes where Titans
have changed judges have changed order
are outdated on the provisions
based on the changes have been saying
that the coffee has been different today
we have been included in the report the
sound is working with parties working
papers showing significant change if
they propose and what is included in the
garage well unfortunately one of the
events like a recommendation to included
provision for introduction saying I
apprecially being renewed this is at the
bottom of page 57 of your of your copies
of your agenda it relates to partition
participation at planning Point seed by
members who are the same order of the
application of them it was suggested two
years ago that the constitution ensure
that the number can speak plants need
this part of the benefit of their own
certain advantages Council however
declined to make this a Parker
constitution on rules unfortunately it
was still included in the compensation
it has never been applied so now we want
to remove this provision this is not
included in regards the Constitution you
have influencing by approving glass and
organizations
you if there are any questions on any
particular points I'll tell my best to
answer them
are there any comments or questions
thank you
um I would like to propose an amendment
to remove the ones related to 10.3 at
10.4 in the suggestion
I very much like the chair for
community's worth and as the federal
government to start with me to protect
the right
and members of this Council
because these two actors need to move it
these proposals will not be sure they're
moving the very reason that everyone in
this group is associated today it allows
them to make for at least a 10.
Derbyshire
and by having these still in it means
that the Primitive Act of gay people
through every single member of Wisconsin
and that cannot be arrived in an opening
councils which are blue prices of
Council of Boston was trying to
um deliver and see what it was saying
earlier
during mentoring debate promotions
performed by councilors is one thing but
on a basic level these proposals will
not work if you cast your mind back to
when we are covered the cats like to
adopt some new legislation very quickly
and in order for that legislation with
the council
um once these have passed you would have
to essentially suspense done in order in
order for that legislation class
when it suits
any people in the council or it will
essentially silence its members that's
number of reports and I will do it all
countries seriously think about removing
these two just leads to after the
proposal and allow things to continue as
they are and allow members to be to
hoverboards in this chamber when they
require it so please consider
development at this amendment and once
we've passed both of the touchdown
promotional rivers in it but if it does
fail then it goes down
you should speak now
thank you chair I support the uh the
amendment for two reasons
firstly members already have the ability
to remember an emotional points to his
Council and has them
and having the past few years with the
both Administration so to amend the
Constitution to prevent things being
brought direct Council debate is only
unnecessary
secondly we have to accept that
communities the the Committees are a
necessary evil for larger towns and we
understand that in the other ways now
to be heard on every issue but we also
have to accept the original consequence
of that there's a huge range of
experiences
earlier on we heard Council of artists
Maybe
um when it came to expression of both
things that they didn't want any values
in the way of democracy the head of paid
services that the council needed to be
adapted on them quickly into any changes
so by their nature the proposed change
at some point between 10.4 inevitably
surpass democracy but much more
nationalist socialism than the
Democratic motion is about the case the
final Nation who now hold the majority
by AJ all members about the amendment
and to reject the proposed changes on
those two elements
thank you so what we're going to do now
is debate this amendment that's been
proposed by County shipment seconded by
councilor Hannah Fox so this part is
that debate now councilman Dale
requiring them to go to expanded before
they are sort of Institutions and become
part of the Constitution and as it said
in the in the in the sort of explanatory
columns but to ensure that the
constitution is amended following due
consideration and not in an adult way I
mean I think I've brought it before what
what the proposed changes people could
do here we wouldn't want Constitution
being picked apart bit by the each
meeting until we all lose track of
what's Happening Constitution I think
it's important that we that we don't uh
change it in that way and that it does
go through some consideration so even
you know putting aside for fact that
we're now on the opposition basis and
locked in the administration I don't
think that's the right process that I
would suggest that most counselors can
do something similar they wouldn't uh
you know on an adult basis each Council
we can make changes to the Constitution
without going to some sort of reviewing
process by standards otherwise
so that will be my take on it I I don't
think you think about limiting the
Constitution particularly or limited
emotions it's about limiting emotions
that specifically change the
Constitution and I think that's
certainly the right way of doing it
Council julitt
I I cannot see anything wrong with
having a proper phone again that
requires any changes
by the standard committee
are the proper consideration by the
officers you advise together and that's
what we're going to give today
so just to allow members today we're
supposed to be uh
like
but the secondly this would be asked for
politics and any policy that's brought
by the executive could open in perfect
it has to have recommendations for
various offices in finance personnel
and that is how it is it should be the
case again
what was the policy that could have huge
consequences in terms of its impact
Financial Services
without proper control
s
um
can you use a comments
not Council shipment to reply
thank you chair
um just to your obvious account what
else has commented on the 10.3 aspects
but there is a 10.4 update that I'm also
um being about in The Commandments which
actually stops any policy change coming
from this Council and think about it
how does counselor get to come to that
scrutinously
what is the mechanism for me if I've got
an idea to take it to a school system
particularly if the chair of that
children who doesn't want it on that
agenda
yeah
and either things that that is the
correct way and in terms of the point
that um Council of Gillette made in that
any Council can bring a policy forward
if that doesn't get access until the
majority of people in this chamber vote
for it that's the beauty before we can
bring something here to be debated on
and whatever majority is an establishing
on that very day it will even be vote
before or again
for them to look at or at least the
councils debated in this chamber and
it's not it's simple someone who is
terrible is a gatekeeper and I seriously
think that this is going down a
dangerous rabbit that we shouldn't be
and I think like I say vaccine
that was Council shipment was built um
reply so we're at the end of the event
so we're voting on the amendment from
the Thousand shipment that we removed
10.3 and 10.4 that's correct
so all those in favor of the amendment
to remove 10.3 and 10.4 please show your
hands
all those again
the abstentions
the amendment is loss
so we come back to the discussion about
the Constitution constitutive
thanks yeah
um I mean this might be linked to some
extent to what would you substitutize
obviously it's way to finish
um but I was in a very uh sort of in a
minimum uh for 16.1 in the proposed
Constitution but otherwise is that age
55 I think of our our packages not
numbers
um our groups we've got concerns about
these proposal we limit the number of
features that planning committee
understand why this is coming forward uh
or been considered in relation to I
think it was a recent application
indicator where there were reported to
students
um but from that opening some sounds
perspective that Council of names
um
I I do think that you know planning
other than your business or you grasping
empty planning into the one time that
you would have uh you know sort of
face-to-face impact with the council
very rarely we get and then we get big
consensus applications which very rarely
you can get more than a couple of
speakers of Supplication and I think I'm
obvious I'm not I'm planning committee
but I think that it's the sort of Rights
and the things that he is residents or
again and to allow them to have their
sayings and if it takes an afternoon and
I think in the case that there would be
a lot of features I think you know that
the hopes to get together and sort of uh
our planet together
um so I think the the limit of five
features is quite all the trees you know
for instance there's three more numbers
come and seeing Awards put themselves
forward there's already no members of
the public pretty much can speak
um and then also the second one with
that the proposal change in relation to
it in both concerts so again I think
that's dangerous it's a bit of a relax
because it's almost a bit of an items
and game show of that's his finger for
reply to the winners so my dreams we're
going to put them down and I'd like to
propose an amendment that this change
16.1 is um
or deferred or removed and considered
but I mean noticing on the previous
point that the live demon groups made I
just wonder whether someone is not
opposed of the report yet as to whether
we should just uh defer the Constitution
changes to have a bit of a look at them
in a bit of a debate so I'm happy to
everyone who likes that I would like to
put down remembrance
as well
um is there a second before I come to
the debate so councildale
I don't know what I'm back again
because we have we have every word in
there we have removed we had before and
we had to come see that so what is it
is
speaking to my faculty
um taking rocket points because of
points around 10.4 I actually think in
10.3 I'm fine with assembly for uh yeah
some concerns about
um particularly on the planning stages
uh for you know we know that developers
will often speak to support their own
applications and if it is
not a very fast you know faster on the
finger developer uh putting forward all
of their all of their friends would be
in support of an application and give it
to be a warp view of it so uh I
definitely have some very serious
concerns around that one and so just be
clear that your Amendment then proposed
on a second is that all changes are
deferred the consideration package
damage
[Music]
um
the first thing of that particular
exchange was one of entertainment
obviously the chair of that police is no
longer yeah if the rationale behind me
you mean like all all the majority group
agreed it takes time
unanimous amongst everybody there I take
on board the concern regarding that
planning and therefore its proposal has
been
um the rest of the details and vote on
the rest but you can delete that one I
would yeah
without that out yes
I mean it wasn't being at all about
let's get directing a lot of the minor
changes
and so look at that planning history
it was such a friendly Amendment the
amendment or
component
you're accepting the
friendly management
yeah I'm happy
looking up here look at any of the other
changes uh throughout the years
thank you I think my understanding is
so again pretority what we're now
agreeing is that um the amendment is to
look at 16.1 by deferring that the
standards committee
um that part only which refers to the
Planning Commission
that's how you know
not an amendment to the memories
is not although actually it might have
helped beforehand because I was actually
going to support Charlotte and Alex with
the original motion to move it the whole
thing back I wasn't the last solution in
committee and these changes weren't
actually great like originally we agreed
to put them to the council we did the
three of them we felt that they were
some of them were rather contentious and
it wasn't our place to me because of
that thing so I would have supported the
amendment to to send the whole thing
back
um I mean yeah I'll support sending a
business so it would have been better
things
any other comments on this amendment as
amended
now shipment
definitely be going back so it kind of
looked at properly in the cut the colors
is around numbers
not being able to bring motion towards
in general
about the constitution
for the policy change I mean that would
that could be anything a change of
policy it's a change of position
and therefore you know even probably
right after the government to try and
change something as a change of public
policy so I think it does need looking
at and we shouldn't just passed this
really nearly especially given there's a
lot of new councils that have been
elected I think it would be good if
standards this again from the different
Viewpoint uh with the new Administration
thank you chair
um I think the 10.4 today as we've said
that everything's all through and we
just go with the amendment for the
primary which is 10.1 and that gets
referred back to the standard I think
it's councilman said that the
um
Constitution will be looked at
throughout the year
so all those concerns with people are
raising now
output of it we'll look at the open G
course
um so I'd suggest and I've had to move
is
Excel
hey how much but at all this is all gone
very understanding and then someone is
telling me helping Improvement
uh and and obviously that was under the
old uh Administration which we've got
anyway I'm happy to do what James you
said and you'll be friends that we we
look at the the numbers on the speakers
are planning I think that's a fair
argument you've just said that it's very
rare but what I think we should have a
limit we can't go with 20 people beating
them at one time well this was on
forever and ever and It ultimately
you're going to repeat yourself
both people will repeat the same
arguments so I think that's what we are
but I'm still confused why it says that
the standards the mid to have agreed
this and then your team tonight
or questions before I come back to
calcific variety of decline
and you've already spoken Council today
so that's that
any other comments or questions
then constitute that writers bye
will
millions and practices
so the amendment then is the 16.1 of the
Constitution suggested change will be
deferred back to planning for further
consideration
that's the amendment that we're voting
for
all those in favor
all those again
any abstentions
that's Curry
thank you
any other comments or questions about
this paper
so whether or
thank you chair is that the question is
the standards committee a
decision-making committee or does it
make recommendations to broadcast
thank you chair and on this solution the
Constitutional changes it makes
recommendations the counter
any of those
not military recommendations outline so
do we have a proposal
you have a second there
yeah
thank you councilman on with it there
really good all right so uh
those in favor
and on the games
the abstentions
that's Karen thank you for move to item
18 schema delegation thanks Mr Sternberg
thank you thank you chair it is a
constitutional requirement of
specifically among specifically approve
the delegation scheme in the
Constitution so the creative formulas
have the annual meeting uh you've
already in effect agreement with the
previous Authority on your left you have
to do it specifically and that's what
recycling is
and I'll move that yet I've never even
opened them out there any comments or
questions
please remove that then again
thank you councilman Terry for those in
favor
anyone again
the abstentions
and then we moved item 19 operation
emergency rules and special TV stations
over to the leader of the council
it's five months that I've ever seen a
few seconds
thank you very much this is another
report it's constitutional and we have
to consider it now
through divisions currently these are a
hundred thousand revenue and 350 000 to
Capital there is no proposal to change
required 28 days
as you can see from real report this has
not been done in the last 12 months
the financial questions
thank you all those in favor
and again
the abstentions
that's carried thank you very much and
the item 20. there is no urgent business
can I thank you very much for your
attendance and declare the meeting close
thank you thank you